[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
attorneys for the accused michigan
school shooter announced plans for an
insanity defense plus a new sentence for
tiger king star joe exotic how long an
oklahoma court rules he will stay behind
bars and michael avenatti continues the
cross-examination of stormy daniels he's
an egomaniac
he thinks he's the best lawyer who's
ever lived even better than abe lincoln
but will he take the stand in his own
defense but first the gun's going to be
destroyed his property was turned on
wednesday but who was entitled to kyle
rinhaus's 2 million dollar bond angeline
levy is live with friday's courtroom
developments law on crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin just when you thought you'd heard
the last of kyle rainhouse he's back in
the news we now know where his two
million dollars in bail money is going
and what's happening with the gun he
used to kill two men and wound a third
law and crime's angel levy is here with
what happened in court
brian kyle rittenhouse had actually
reached an agreement with his former
lawyer lynn wood and the fight back
foundation over that two million dollar
bail the court approved approval was
just needed the judge needed to sign off
on it but a hedge fund company came in
at the 11th hour and tried to claim the
entire 2 million dollars because it said
it made some sort of a deal with
rittenhouse's former lawyer now kyle
rittenhouse was not in court for this
hearing that took place but he and his
lawyers had agreed that he and fight
back would each get
925 000
and that actor ricky schroeder would get
back a hundred fifty thousand dollars he
donated to the bail fund but a hedge
fund company filed
had a lawyer in court who claimed a
company had invested 300 000 in the bail
fund expecting written house would be
acquitted and that the company expected
to return with interest that company
also claimed another former written
house attorney john pierce owed more
than two million dollars so the fund was
entitled to the bail money since pierce
posted it in the end judge bruce
schroeder said the hedge fund company
had no standing and approved the deal
between rittenhouse fight back and ricky
schroeder
how does that feel it's good it's over
you got what you wanted accomplished in
there yeah we
the gun's going to be destroyed his
property is returned on wednesday and
the money is going to people who divided
up fight back
kyle and uh ricky schroeder who posted
some of it do you know how much his
portion would be kyle's portion
tell us
no
the pillar guy does not get any money
back can you explain why kyle
rittenhouse was so insistent about
destroying or having that gun destroyed
what was his reasoning because
there was dual claims to the gun and
we did not want the gun being returned
to dominic black and then having him
sell it as kyle rittenhouse has gone
like
have happened in other famous cases
dominic black you'll recall was that
friend of kyle rittenhouse's who was
with him that night in august of 2020 he
had actually purchased that gun for kyle
rittenhouse it was in his name so
legally he likely would have been deemed
the owner of it by the court now the
state and written house agreed that the
gun will be destroyed by the state and
that the state will videotape that
process and then
provide a
copy of that recording to the defense
brian
thanks angela joining us today is former
prosecutor melbourne pearson and terry
austin melbourne judge schroeder said
rain house's gun will be destroyed and
interestingly enough it's going to be
videotaped something i think we all want
to see
what'd you think of that decision
i think that that was a solid decision
for all of the reasons that mark
richards itemized i think there's that
ethical and sort of moral responsibility
to make sure that his actions are not
celebrated right because you have to
think about the fact that you know
people lost their lives and there's
family members who are never going to
see their loved ones again as a result
of his actions even though they were
deemed to be legally justifiable so the
destruction of the gun i think sends a
you know clear message that we're not
going to celebrate you know these types
of
killings basically death yeah now terry
crowd funding is becoming more and more
popular in terms of raising money for
bail in these types of cases do you
think the courts need to kind of make a
bright line rule for how this is going
to work in the future and what would it
be
yeah absolutely brian listen i listened
to the entire 43-minute hearing it was
long and all of the parties seemed like
they were confused even the judge so i
think we need a clear and consistent
rule and i think it should be applied
even federally although this is criminal
i think it could go to the ethical
considerations as far as a lawyer's
practice is concerned so what you want
to do is make sure defense counsel is
not involved with the fundraising make
sure that the funds are used
specifically for what they're supposed
to be used for and make sure that the
investors know that they are using the
money the way it's supposed to be used
so frankly i just think it should be
revamped federally
yeah i think it will help a lot and
probably uh
other people in the stories we'll cover
later we'll be asking questions about
what do i do with my clients money like
avenatti and jeannette the fight over
the bail could have gone ugly and it
almost did right
yeah that's exactly right brian you know
kyle rittenhouse's mother
had said a while back she had told law
and crime.com that she wanted a full
accounting of the money that had been
raised through the fightback foundation
and it sounded like kyle rittenhouse was
really expecting to get that full two
million dollars back but the fight back
foundation i had spoken with lynn wood
about it briefly uh in the last month or
so and he said that fight back raised a
lot of that money through strictly
through the fight back foundation for
other means and by other means so he
said he was willing to help kyle out the
foundation was with some of his expenses
that were still outstanding so um kyle
had kind of taken some swings at
lynnwood in the press
and obviously they've worked this out to
the satisfaction of both sides all right
sounds interesting we'll see we'll wait
and see when that video comes out and
that'll be the next big thing in this
the case of kyle randhouse thank you
everyone for contributing all right
switching now to news out of texas where
officials say the man responsible for
the death of a houston corporal has been
on the run since get this 1996. they
also say he's wanted for another murder
in el salvador on wednesday oscar
rosales was arrested in connection to
the death of corporal charles galloway
investigators say rosales shot and
killed galloway early sunday morning
during a traffic stop his arrest came
days later when he was found more than
600 miles from houston in mexico at a
press conference on thursday the harris
county district attorney confirmed
rosalis was wanted in connection to a
murder in el salvador and a 1996 charge
for absconding from probation she says
rosales will face the strictest sentence
possible for his history of violence
cartel or gang affiliations and capital
murder charge
oscar rosales the defendant
viciously executed
corporal galloway
he violated this sacred oath of the
officer who was in the line of duty
by killing him the crime of capital
murder can only end two ways
in the death penalty
or in life without parole
this case has all the ear markings and
is a death penalty case
an update now on the brett hankinson
trial out of kentucky jury selection
began on friday following a judge's rule
that cameras will be allowed during the
trial on thursday jefferson county judge
and bailey smith denied the defense
request to ban news outlets from the
courtroom but did rule cameras cannot
roll during individual voidier for
potential jurors henkeson is the only
officer charged in connection to the
death but not for the death of unarmed
black woman brianna taylor in march 2020
hankinson and two other officers forced
their way into taylor's apartment
authorized by a search warrant taylor's
boyfriend thinking they were intruders
fired a warning shot taylor was shot and
killed as officers responded with
gunfire hankinson is charged with wanton
endangerment as prosecutors say he
endangered the safety of people in an
apartment neighboring tailors jury
selection is expected to last for weeks
as hundreds of potential jurors are
questioned
still ahead on law and crime daily tiger
king star joe exotic is resentenced in
the murder for hire plot to kill carol
baskin but first cross-examination heats
up as michael avenatti questions his
former client stormy daniels but will
the defendant take the stand that's next
on law and crime daily
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law in crime daily
cross-examination takes a bizarre turn
in federal court as disgrace attorney
michael avenatti questions his former
client stormy daniels about her belief
in the paranormal
avenatti pushed to represent himself in
the federal trial as prosecutors allege
he stole 300 thousand dollars from
daniels daniels an adult film actress
whose real name is stephanie clifford
rose to fame after news broke of an
affair with former president donald
trump her tell-all book full disclosure
details the affair prosecutors say
avenatti stole advance
advances for that book deal saying he
used the money to pay employees at his
law firm and make luxury car payments on
thursday and friday daniels took the
stand as the government star witness
avenatti questioned her about her belief
in ghosts the supernatural and whether
she believed she could speak to dead
people but as legal analyst gene rossi
explains avenatti himself could also
take the stand
you represent yourself you can take the
stand
and you if you've got a judge that
really wants to reign you in
that judge will make you state a
question
that can be adapted to and you will
answer your own question
if i were the judge and i've seen it you
ask a question of yourself
and you answer it i'm not going to let
you get up here just do a narrative and
a speech like edward everett the
two-hour speech before uh lincoln's
getting further dressed you're gonna do
a question and answer he asks himself
the old question because you got to have
that for purposes of objections and the
appeal
all right before i start asking
questions of myself let's bring back
former prosecutor melbourne pearson and
terry austin to break down avenatti's
cross terry the credibility of an
alleged victim is always in question but
is attacking daniel's belief in the
paranormal sound like a successful
tactic
it's not a tactic i would use brian i
mean some of the jurors could go for it
they might actually question her
credibility her judgment particularly
the fact that anyone would agree to
represent someone else for a hundred
dollars but the tactic could really
backfire because there are many people
who believe in the paranormal and some
of those jurors might resent avenatti
for attacking her beliefs everyone has a
right to believe what they want and more
importantly brian some might think it's
not at all relevant so it might backfire
on him yeah now melba i was there in
court today and after the
cross-examination and recross and all
that of stormy daniels avenatti actually
said he is quote strongly leaning
towards taking the stand how do you
think that's going to play out for him
i don't think it's going to end well for
him i don't see how he can move forward
in this case without getting on the
stand but i don't think he's going to be
able to sway jurors because of that
brash high profile personality that he
has been exhibiting over the course of
the last few years and it can be very
off-putting especially in this type of
scenario where you have someone who is
alleging this massive fraud so he's
going to have to get on the stand to
explain the conversations that he had
with her and why he believes he's
entitled to this money but i don't think
it's going to sway the jurors at all
yeah especially from his
cross-examination he seemed to kind of
go around the issue of this signature
and money going into a separate account
i don't know maybe he'll have some
questions for himself to answer i've
never seen that before but i believe in
gene rossi's description of that it'll
be interesting to see how that plays out
next week thank you both
this week on prime crime host jesse
weber takes a deep dive into a case out
of ohio which left a toddler dead and a
babysitter behind bars he joins us now
with a look ahead jesse
hey there brian yeah our next episode is
about the death of a three-year-old girl
named hannah weshee and the babysitter
accused of killing her that woman is
lindsay parton now she claims she wasn't
responsible for the toddler's death yet
it's all about what she says not just in
one but two police interviews
whatever happened to her happens
she has
i'm absolutely telling you the truth
always wrong the way it's looking right
now is that this happened at your house
because
we need we need to find out i swear to
god i'm telling you the exact truth we
walked in there
she did not walk she did not talk with
this type of injury
but it doesn't end there because lindsay
parton also took the stand which threw
in a whole other layer to this story
tune in to lawn crime
thanks jesse you can catch this week's
episode of prime crime friday night at 5
30 pm and 10 30 pm eastern here on the
law and crime network
coming up on law and crime daily an
update on accused school shooter ethan
crumbly as his legal team announces the
focus of their defense plus tiger king's
star joe exotic is re-sentenced in
oklahoma court but will he face less
time for his crimes the answer is next
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
netflix star joe exotic will spend a
little less time in prison for his
crimes after being re-sentenced on
friday but his plea to be freed was
denied a federal appeals court ruled the
tiger king star should get a shorter
prison sentence for his part in the
murder for hire plot against animal
civil rights activist carol baskin and
for violating violating wildlife laws
joe exotic was sentenced in january 2020
to 22 years in federal prison a panel
for the u.s court of appeals found the
trial court gave the wrong calculations
for his prison term the former zookeeper
was re-sentenced to 21 years behind bars
former prosecutor in melbourne pearson
and co-host terry austin is back to
break down joe exotic's sentencing now
terry a federal judge said that the
sentencing was a little off at first it
was uh 22 to 27 years now supposed to be
17 to 22. couldn't the judge have just
said hey you know what we're going to be
22 years and that's it but it only
dropped by a year so is that a win for
joe or not
i don't think it's a win for him i mean
dropping it by one year is certainly not
a win when it's the difference between
22 and 21. i think the judge essentially
disregarded all of exotic's arguments i
mean they completely ignored the
community support and i actually think
that joe exotic had some good arguments
here i mean granted he was convicted of
murder for hire and that's a very
serious charge but i didn't think
frankly that the evidence was good
against him and i think that at this
point he certainly is not a threat to
society so i don't think this was a win
for him and i think people are
disappointed yeah now i agree with terry
i think the judge kind of heard the
arguments i was like all right 12 months
i'll just go down a little but should
the fact that joe exotic is fighting
prostate cancer be a reason to reduce a
sentence even more
it can be a very solid reason to reduce
the sentence because if you think about
it if you have a terminal condition of
which prostate cancer most cancers would
be considered to be a terminal condition
that's usually ground to get you an
earlier release or basically like a
conditional release where you can go
home to basically live your last days
with your family and loved ones so since
that can be grounds for a reduction of
your sentence or an early release then
it should have been taken into
consideration
in terms of this resentencing but
clearly the judge was having none of it
and that's why he ended up with 21 years
all right we'll see where this goes i'm
expecting joe exotic to have quite a few
words about just that one year reduction
in his sentence thank you both when we
come back a fifteen-year-old suspect
will argue the insanity defense what
that means for michigan school shooter
ethan crumbly and how his claims that he
was mentally ill at the time of the
shooting will affect the case those
disturbing details still ahead
[Music]
welcome back we look now to michigan
where suspected school shooter ethan
crumbly will argue an insanity defense
at trial fifteen-year-old crumbly is
accused of killing four people and
injuring seven others in a shooting at
oxford high school in november the teen
faces 24 charges of those charges you've
got four counts of first-degree murder
and one count of terrorism he's being
tried as an adult even though he was 15
at the time of the shooting before
allegedly opening fire on his classmates
teacher reported concerning behavior
from crumbly which including these
disturbing photos you're seeing of a gun
and a person bleeding other concerning
evidence show the teenager allegedly
killed animals and even stored the head
of a dead bird inside of a jar
crumbley's parents james and jennifer
are also charged in relation to the
shooting after allegedly disregarding
warning signs that their son was a
danger prosecutors also say they allowed
him easy access to the use of a gun
crumbly and his parents have pled not
guilty to all charges under michigan law
crumbly will now undergo a psychiatric
evaluation to determine whether he was
mentally ill or intellectually disabled
at the time of the shooting
melbourne an insanity defense it seemed
to be the obvious move here how does it
work and do you see it as a strong
defense in this case
i don't know if it's going to be a
strong defense in this case but
definitely it is a viable one so
basically the defense is going to say
listen we know we did it ethan you know
the defendant did in fact shoot these
people and take their lives however at
the time of the offense he did not
understand right from wrong he did not
understand that his actions were wrong
and could result in death so that is
what they're going to advance as their
theory they will have the drawings that
they can point to as well as some of the
other disturbing behaviors that he's
exhibited but the question is going to
be what were his actions right up until
and right after the incident and how can
that shape whether or not
what showing what his mental state was
that's going to be the question yeah i
see those drawings being a real
issue for them though because he kind of
scribbles them out afterwards making it
seem like he knew they were kind of bad
but we'll save that for the trial terry
there are different cases totally get
that but could ethan's medical records
and a potential insanity defense affect
the crumbly parents case and even
potential civil lawsuits against oxford
high school
well i do think that the case against
ethan and the case against his parents
will have different charges of course so
the evidence is going to vary and as far
as the civil case is concerned clearly
it's going to have different evidence
and obviously a different burden of
proof but i do think that that insanity
defense could actually help both the
parents and the school
because they could say that they didn't
know that he was going to snap and they
had no control and they didn't
anticipate his behavior so if he is
deemed to be insane and that does come
into the other cases it could very well
help both the parents and the school as
far as their claim is concerned or their
defense
all right we'll see how that evaluation
comes back thank you both and thank you
for joining us here at law on crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you